خزانات اوكرانيا بات التفيض بصواريخ غربيه
تختلف بالمدى والدقه لكن الهديه
البريطانيه الاحدث قد تغير وقائع المعركه
كيف بدات باستخدام اكثر سلاح متقدم طلقته
منذ بدء الحرب وهو صاروخ ستورم شادو صاروخ
كروز بعيد المدى طورته بريطانيا وفرنسا
بشكل مشترك يزيد مدى على 250 كيلومترا هذه
هي المسافه اقل بقليل من مدى انظمه صواريخ
ارض ارض تكتيكيه الامريكيه الصنع والمقدره
ب 297 كيلومترا والتي طالب بها زيلينسكي
مرارا اذا يتجه الى هدفه بسرعه
987 كيلومترا في الساعه او 0.8 من سرعه
الصوت يمكن اطلاقه من الارض او باستخدام
الطائرات بل يمكن تركيبه على الطائرات
السوفيتيه الصنع التي تستخدمها القوات
الاوكرانيه قبل الوص هدف يمتلك تقنيه
حديثه هي تعمل بالاشعه تحت الحمراء وينخفض
تحت الارتفاعات المعروفه لتجنب اكتشافه من
قبل الرادارات بشكل عام هذا الصاروخ يهدد
الاراضي الروسيه ويتيح الكييف الوصول
لجميع الاقاليم الاوكرانيه التي ضمتها
روسيا كشبه جزيره القرمبا مثلا وبالتالي
استهداف خطوط الامداد وذخيره ومستودعات
الوقود هناك تطورات دافعت بالقوات الروسيه
لابعاد مواقع قياداتها ولوجوسياتها بعيدا
عن الخطوط الاماميه تحسبا لاي استهدافات
غير ان حساباتها يمكن التغلب عليها باطلاق
الصاروخ من الطائره ببساطه لكن خبراء
عسكريين قللوا من امكانيه قلب هذه
المعادله للصواريخ نظرا الى كلفتها
العاليه والمقدره بثمن مئه الف يورو
للصاروخ الواحد وايضا محدوديه المخزونات
الغربيه منها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات